uh one of the things we did not get to
cover yesterday when we covered the
wacky weekend in georgia with trumpists
and marjorie taylor greene and matt
gates and all of these other people was
that uh john bachmann a newsmax host i'm
not i'm not very familiar with john
bachman
john bachman was allowed i guess to
interview donald trump right before his
speech on saturday
it is a bizarre interview trump looks
visibly confused he doesn't seems
disoriented and the things he's saying
make just as little sense as trump's
physical appearance let's take a look at
this trump just uncontrollably lying and
even seems confused about the lies he's
telling let's talk about this lawsuit
against hillary clinton what do you hope
to accomplish with that well they
spotted my campaign you had all of them
there remember there is still no proof
that anybody spied on his campaign all
the names are there all the names you've
been reading about for years bill barr
didn't want to be impeached and so
therefore he decided not to do it which
was a shame because frankly you know you
need courage to fight these people deep
state or whatever you want to call them
but uh trump's still talking about the
deep state i mean fully in to so many of
these different conspiracy theories i
think we're going to do very well with
it we have a great lawsuit and
i felt it was
really very important to bring it
because
think of it if i spied on their campaign
can you imagine what would happen john
now remember the lawsuit as we talked
about yesterday will go nowhere if the
lawsuit were to proceed
trump would be subject to discovery and
the last thing trump would ever allow
is for himself to be put under oath and
deposed it's just the lawsuit's going
nowhere you guys know that spied on
their campaign on obama or biden or in
hillary clinton
and the same thing happened where we
caught him because we caught him
red-handed
if that ever happened
what are they talking about treason are
they talking about the rest of your life
in jail are they talking about death
penalty
and these people can't be allowed to get
away with this stuff right so trump uh
trump suggesting that something that
didn't happen is actually treason trump
then seemingly blaming joe biden
for putin
maybe using nukes this is bizarre stuff
let's also talk about russia and ukraine
seems like uh putin may have
miscalculated there what is your
assessment of where things stand right
now with putin's invasion of ukraine
well you never know i can tell you the
country is just in shambles you look at
these cities they've been bombed and
they've been blown up and it's going to
take 50 to 100 years to rebuild them
and so many people have been killed so
many people have been killed and
horribly
wounded but i will tell you that
it should have never happened this would
have never happened had the election not
been rigged this would have never
happened he would have never in a
million years have done it so
it's very sad when i watch it it's sad
because
this is something all those people
should be living now they should not be
dead do you think putin would use
nuclear weapons
when you put them into a corner and when
you talk the way they're talking you
know they're talking weak and yet
they're almost giving him an incentive
it's uh they're handling him very badly
in my opinion
i think that biden apologized again
today he's apologized every time he
makes a speech he apologizes
three four times a day for everything he
says look
we have people that don't know what
they're doing yeah so anyway if if putin
uses nuclear weapons it is not going to
be joe biden's fault and then lastly
trump commenting on
approval ratings i have no idea if he's
going to run i can't imagine he does
well he's got the lowest approval rating
in history in the history of a president
which is pretty low and
if he does uh and if i decide i'd love
to run against him i can tell you who
would be now of course uh donald trump's
approval ratings at this point in his
presidency were lower than those of joe
biden so quite literally all lies it's
lies all the way down
and trump just is seeming very confused
when you look at him and when you listen
to him it's all very bizarre
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
one stop shop for easy healthy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
if you're a parent of any age child
little spoon makes healthy meal times
simpler
and it saves you hours at a very
reasonable price
little spoon makes everything fresh just
like homemade but it's delivered to your
door and ready in seconds pop it in the
fridge or freezer and it is ready when
you are they have 100 percent organic
cold pressed baby food for every eating
stage awesome food for toddlers and for
kids they even just launched a new line
of on-the-go smoothies that kids love
everything is nutritionally balanced no
junk food but it is kid approved it's
food that they'll actually eat and enjoy
and you can't beat the prices with kids
meals under five dollars baby food and
smoothie snacks under three dollars
little spoon is giving my audience 50
off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use the code pacman
the link is down below